this tragedy shook europeans  in april around 800 migrants died as  their boat sank in the mediterranean  since then the eu has troubled the  budget for triton its border protection  mission  now european governments are poised to  take further action  the bloc's foreign policy chief federica  mogherini wants un backing for eu  military operations against people  smugglers  addressing this situation is first of  all a moral duty for us  but it is also a shared interest of all  countries involved  the ones around the mediterranean as  well as countries of origin and transit  we are here to act immediately and to  act together  we need an exceptional response  but rights groups say eu plans to  destroy trafficker boats in libyan  waters could trap migrants in the  war-torn country and the eu needs  unapproval to make the idea a reality so  mogherini appealed to the security  council seeking support for a potential  european resolution authorizing military  missions  you